G herbo my guy my brother my brother
good to see you man always likewise uh
survivor's remorse is a uh
that's a deep title man and it's
something that a lot of people go
through you know when you come from
certain backgrounds and you know you
learn you learn or you lose people in
your life to the streets to other things
like kind of dive into let's just kick
it off Man dive into survivor's remorse
bro
survivor's remorse man for me is
you know it's it's deeper than just the
album title is
where I am mentally in my life you know
what I'm saying as a man
um having overcame so much adversity and
like
bro it's it's crazy because my
circumstances when I first started
rapping let me just go back to in
general when I first started rapping
when I first made my first ever Rap God
I wasn't trying to I was
the first time I made a rap like on some
like recording of [ __ ] yeah yeah little
herb [ __ ]
15 15 years old okay
um probably 14 14 going on 15 or
something like that I was 14 a freshman
in high school so like 14 or 15.
um
and when I did that I wasn't trying to
like
become a rapper like my dreams and
aspirations was never to become a rapper
like I want to become this big Superstar
nothing like that I was rapping trying
to like put on for my hood be the voice
for my neighborhood you know what I'm
saying and talk about what I was feeling
what I was going through like I wasn't I
didn't know what a manager was an A and
R uh record label I didn't know what
none of that was bro I didn't know
anything about that
I just was recording a song on my app on
my flip phone over a YouTube beat and I
send it to my homies for them to hear
you know what I'm saying it just picked
up naturally you know and I still wasn't
it didn't grasp me you know what I'm
saying I'm saying that to say like I
mean you're a kid I was a kid you feel
me and when I started to
become a rapper I was still a kid you
know so survivors remorse for me is
coming from that being in the most
dangerous neighborhood you know I'm
saying one of the most dangerous
neighborhoods in Chicago and just trying
to find a way to get my thoughts out you
know I'm saying I always knew how to rap
it was just a way for me to like Express
what I'm going through in the hood and
for my homies to hear it to relate to it
you know what I'm saying and to have
that and turn it into this and to be
able to overcome
deaf prison
uh drug addiction like all of that all
of these things and BG herbo today be
who I am today you know what I'm saying
and that's what being a Survivor is for
me you know I'm saying I survived my
circumstance I don't never have to go
back to living that way you know what
I'm saying and the remorse side of it is
everything I lost along the way you know
a lot of my best friends my brother
um
just so much you know just in the
thought of so many people that I love
that I actually care about still being
in poverty still being under these
circumstances you know I'm saying and me
wanting to help them me wanting to show
them this other side of life because
I've experienced it and understanding
that you can't do that for everybody
understanding that everybody not gonna
want that for themselves you know and
it's a constant battle you feel I'm
saying like
I have to to smile and be charismatic
and do interviews be a leader press be a
leader you know what I'm saying be a
role model for so many people that look
up to me and I don't get a chance to
really just sit back and
reflect on life or sit back and just you
know feed my my mental stability you
know what I'm saying like yeah and
grieve or whatever the case may be you
know what I'm saying I can't really have
a bad day all day there's no such thing
as me really being mad all day I've
never experienced it for real you don't
have the luxury of it I don't have the
luxury to just be pissed off all day or
be sad all day I don't have it right so
that's the remorse side of it you know
what I'm saying like and that's crazy
and I'm blessed to just be the type of
person where I'm not even that kind of
guy like no matter what I'm going
through or how I'm feeling I'm not gonna
never be mad upset all day angry all day
I don't even understand how that's
possible Right but people really like
that people really walk around mad sad
angry all day because of what they going
through and I just know I'm blessed no
matter what it is I don't give a [ __ ] if
I was dead broke I've experienced enough
life to know that I'm blessed no matter
what I'm alive my kids good whatever the
[ __ ] the case may be you know what I'm
saying so that's survivors remorse to me
you know just where I am mentally like
you know what I'm saying just trying to
create balance for myself you feel me
because
at the end of the day you don't really
change I'm still that same person and
it's probably the deepest explanation
that I've given about the title you know
I'm saying because I'm still that same
person I'm still that same kid from same
life as you feel me but I'm G herbo I'm
a father I'm a leader I'm a a
philanthropist I'm a so many things
where I can't really dwell on one moment
I just gotta keep on trying to get
better and better and that's if I was
immersed you know I'm saying I just
gotta you know keep a Level Playing
Field